alguna vez os habéis preguntado Cuál es
el país del mundo en el que más llueve
eh No antes de que os anticipáis esta
vez la respuesta no tiene absolutamente
nada que ver con el título de este vídeo
el país donde más llueve de todo el
planeta no es otro que Colombia pero no
este vídeo no va sobre el país del café
la bandeja paisa y el sancocho queridos
amigos amigas A pesar de no ser el
número uno nuestro protagonista de hoy
Singapur sí está en la parte alta muy
alta de este particular ranking mundial
en concreto ocupa la décimo cuarta Plaza
con unos 2400 mm al año de
precipitaciones medias Así que no sé lo
primero que podríamos pensar es que
Singapur sobre el agua verdad pues no O
al menos no Exactamente lo cierto Es que
a pesar de ser uno de los países más
pasados por agua de todo el planeta
sufren problemas de escasez Así que aquí
no surgen dos preguntas clave como
demonios es posible que sufran escasez
de agua con todo lo que llueve Y qué ha
hecho y qué piensa hacer Singapur para
atajar este problema queridos amigos
amigas os acordáis del vídeo que hicimos
sobre Israel y el milagro del agua pues
ojo porque los hijos de merlion no se
quieren quedar atentos
si sois seguidores habituales de
visualpolitik Seguro seguro que conocéis
a nuestro patrocinador de hoy vinchero
collective
en esta ocasión nos creemos presentar el
nuevo argo automático
con cuerpo y correa de acero inoxidable
quirúrgico una resistencia al agua de
hasta 20 atmósferas y cristal de Zafiro
a prueba de arañazos este reloj no
necesitará que nunca le cambien las
pilas porque sorpresa no tiene pilas Sí
sí lo habéis escuchado bien con su
mecanismo miyota automático este reloj
se recarga con el propio movimiento de
tu cuerpo y si por cualquier motivo os
lo queréis quitar cuenta además con una
batería de respaldo que le garantiza
hasta 40 horas de funcionamiento todo
así de sencillo es decir que ya nunca
más vas a tener que volver a pasar por
esa horrible Sensación del reloj al que
se le agotan las pilas y luego nunca te
acuerdas de cambiarlas y no sé a
vosotros pero a mí esto me ha ganado del
todo porque me pasa constantemente y qué
queréis que os diga a mí este color
verde la verdad es que me gusta un
montón No sé me parece clásico pero
también a la vez fresco y rompedor no me
digáis que no le da un puntito de todas
formas lo tenéis en otros cuatro colores
diferentes y os preguntaréis pero es
realmente resistente qué ocurre si lo
pido me llega y luego no me convence
Pues atentos porque a mí esto Me encanta
muy muy importante mi hincheros están
tan convencidos de la calidad de sus
relojes que te ofrecen cinco años de
garantía y un periodo de devolución de
365 días Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien
os lo Vais a poder pensar durante todo
un año y si luego no os convence pues lo
podéis devolver o cambiarlo por otro Eso
sí siempre y cuando el reloj esté
intacto Claro pero un momento porque
ahora viene lo mejor de todo por ser
miembros de la comunidad visualpolitik
Vais a poder haceros con el nuevo argo
con un 15% de descuento y envío gratuito
tan solo tendréis que utilizar el código
político en vinchero
collective.com/politik así de fácil y
ahora sí arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
como podríamos en mega project Singapur
es un país fascinante un lugar del que
por cierto nos encanta hablar aquí en
visualpolitik ahora bien aunque
normalmente nos ocupamos de cuestiones
como la seguridad jurídica el modelo
económico o incluso la defensa militar
esta vez vamos a echar un vistazo a un
tema radicalmente diferente el agua lo
sé lo sé seguro que en este preciso
momento muchos os preguntáis pero a ver
Enrique qué demonios tiene que ver el
agua con la política que no sé al fin y
al cabo es de lo que se supone trata
este canal pues sabéis que lo cierto Es
que tienen mucha pero que mucha relación
Mucha más de la que podréis imaginar a
simple vista
[Música]
a pesar de que Singapur es uno de los
países donde más llueve de todo el mundo
el problema es que también es uno de los
más densamente poblados con unos 5
millones y medio de habitantes en una
superficie de poco más de 700 kilómetros
cuadrados no hay suficientes espacio
para almacenar el agua dulce que cae en
forma de lluvia claro os imagináis por
ejemplo un gran embalse en plena ciudad
seguro que no en total esta ciudad
estado tiene 17 embalses de captación de
agua pero lógicamente la mayoría son muy
pequeños y no son capaces de satisfacer
la enorme demanda de agua que tiene esta
ciudad es precisamente por este motivo
por el que la gestión del agua se ha
convertido en una cuestión clave en la
política del país
[Música]
de hecho Singapur es considerado uno de
los países con más estrés hídrico del
mundo y ocupa la primera posición entre
los 33 países en riesgo extremo de
estrés hídrico para el 2040 claro
Gracias a su prosperidad económica a la
ciudad No para de crecer y con ella
también la demanda de agua fijaos
[Música]
Claro que no se trata solo de la
población a pesar de ser un país
eminentemente urbano más del 55% de toda
la demanda de agua procede de la
actividad económica no de los hogares un
porcentaje que además esperas incrementa
hasta el 70% para el año 2060 ya os he
dicho que Singapur no deja de crecer
Industrial turismo o incluso
experimentos agrícolas de los que por
cierto ellos hablamos en un vídeo pasado
aquí en visualpolity Así que con todo
esto en mente La pregunta es cómo
diantres se puede garantizar el
suministro de agua en un país con un
territorio cada vez más presionado por
la creciente acumulación de viviendas
industrias hoteles y comercios de todo
tipo Qué plan se guardan bajo la manga
en uno de los territorios más ricos y
prósperos del planeta Pues bien veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el agua también es política
ya os lo hemos dicho la ciudad del león
con cuerpo de pez es uno de los lugares
más urbanizados densamente poblados y
más dependientes del mundo lo que
respecta al agua y claro la capacidad
para construir infraestructuras es a
priori limitada y es una cuestión
básicamente de metros cuadrados por eso
aproximadamente la mitad de todo el agua
que se consume en el país es importada
de su vecino más próximo Malasia y
sabéis que justo aquí donde se produce
todo el jaleo el politiqueo puro y duro
en toda esta cuestión porque he queridos
amigos amigas el suministro de agua en
esta ciudad estado hoy por hoy depende
fundamentalmente de un acuerdo muy
antiguo y muy bien negociado por parte
de Singapur un acuerdo con las
autoridades del estado de jojor que no
gusta nada pero que nada de nada al
gobierno malasio
[Música]
gracias al acuerdo con el estado de
jojor Singapur opera una presa que le
permite importar actualmente cerca de
900 millones de litros diarios de agua
sin tratar desde el país vecino el
problema para los malasios es su precio
las autoridades singapurenses y las del
estado de York acordaron una
compensación por el agua extraída de 3
Send malasios por cada mil galones Lo
que equivale a unos 0,007 dólares
americanos por cada
3.785 litros de agua el motivo de que el
precio sea tan irrisorio es que no puede
ser modificado unilateralmente el
acuerdo que entró en vigor en 1962 y es
válido por 99 años Establece que ese
precio no podría modificarse
transcurridos los primeros 25 años es
decir que el precio desde 1987 es
invariable
y eso no es todo el acuerdo incluye
también una cláusula y le obliga
Singapur a revender de nuevo a George
hasta el 2% del agua que importa Después
de ser tratada y potabilizada a un
precioso Si de 50c por cada mil galones
Es decir para que nos entendamos
Singapur importa mil galones de agua sin
tratar a tres en y luego vende mil
galones de agua tratabas a 50 con este
ajuste prácticamente se pagan un
porcentaje muy importante de todo el
agua consumida además para colmo el
acuerdo tampoco estableció ningún tipo
de revisión del precio en base a la
inflación ni nada por el estilo no sé un
buen acuerdo para Singapur no os parece
Singapur claro y consistente en la
posición de que Malasia ha perdido su
derecho a revisar el precio del agua
bajo el acuerdo de 1962 Así que tal y
como os podéis imaginar todo esto es
algo que ha generado una enorme
frustración para Malasia
normal el acuerdo implica la práctica
regalarle el agua Singapur Así que se
han producido un montón de tiras y
aflojas y conflictos diplomáticos entre
los dos países precisamente a cuenta del
agua y claro eso es lo que explica en
noticias como esta
revive la disputa del agua con Singapur
califica el acuerdo de 1962 de ridículo
pero ahora bien un momento el acuerdo no
es para siempre
tal y como os hemos dicho tiene una
duración de 99 años lo que significa que
en 2061 Singapur perderá su derecho a
importar a buen condiciones tan
ventajosas Además tal y como ya os
contamos en un pasado vídeo aquí en
visualpolitik Singapur es una especie de
Fortín Así que tampoco quieren tener
tanta dependencia de un tercer país para
algo tan importante lo consideran algo
así como una debilidad estratégica Casi
casi un problema de seguridad nacional y
sí vale lo sé para que llegue el año
2061 aún queda mucho tiempo pero sabéis
que en Singapur Ya se está preparando os
lo hemos dicho en un montón de vídeos a
esta gente ser precavido así que dicho y
hecho el gobierno de Singapur se ha
marcado como un objetivo fundamental
lograr como muy tarde para el año 2060
la autosuficiencia hídrica un gigante es
correcto para el cual la ciudad estado
ha puesto en marcha un plan que combina
la reducción del consumo el
aprovechamiento de hasta la última gota
Y por supuesto la capacidad de producir
agua limpia por sí mismos conseguir un
suministro abundante económico y
potencialmente ilimitado de agua dulce
pero queréis saber cómo esperan
conseguirlo pues atentos
[Música]
los cuatro grifos de Singapur
amigos Tal y como os comentamos al
principio del vídeo a pesar de que en
Singapur las lluvias son muy abundantes
el problema está en que no tienen agua
subterráneas aprovechables ni tampoco
grandes cuerpos de agua dulce
disponibles desde cajón que no hay sitio
para grandes embalses Pues bien
actualmente y para solventar este
inconveniente la gestión actual del agua
se basa en lo que se ha bautizado como
los cuatro grifos nacionales esto es las
cuatro grandes fuentes de agua del país
la primera de ellas es precisamente la
que se basa en la captación de agua de
las cuencas locales para alimentar una
red de micro embalses y depósitos
[Música]
para potenciar esta Fuente de Agua ya en
1972 Singapur impulsó el conocido como
plan maestro del agua un plan que
consistió en identificar todas las áreas
posibles de captación y embalses para
recolectar el agua de la lluvia y
utilizarla en el sistema de suministro
gracias a este plan se crearon nuevos
embalses hasta alcanzar la cifra de 17
con los que cuenta actualmente entre
ellos un gran embalse urbano que baña el
corazón de esta ciudad de estado
incluyendo su lugar más famoso marina
bay
lo habéis escuchado bien aunque nos
pueda sorprender desde el año 2008 esa
inmensa Laguna La histórica Bahía
característica de Singapur el lugar
donde el merlionvierte sus aguas se ha
convertido en todo un embalse de Agua
Dulce luego del segundo Grifo nacional
ya os hemos hablado es el agua importada
desde Malasia una fuente que
previsiblemente tiene fecha de caducidad
el año 2061 y por último en tercer y
cuarto lugar están respectivamente el
New water y el agua de salinizada y ojo
Porque estos dos grifos nacionales son
de lo más interesante y la clave para
alcanzar la autosuficiencia hídrica en
especial el ni water
[Música]
New water es uno de los sistemas de agua
recuperada o reciclada más avanzados del
mundo y la apuesta principal de Singapur
para lograr la autosuficiencia hídrica
consiste en un sistema de filtrado de
cuatro barreras que convierte agua
residual es decir el agua ya utilizada
en agua potable primero el agua pasa por
un tratamiento de depuración
convencional después pasa por una
segunda fase consistente en sistemas de
micro Y ultrafiltración a través de
membranas extremadamente finas la
tercera etapa consiste en la ósmosis
inversa un sistema de depuración a
presión que elimina moléculas indeseadas
iones grandes partículas y sales y
minerales que no quieres que estén ahí Y
por último como cuarta Barrera se le
aplica rayos ultravioleta que
desinfectan de bacterias el agua
parece un sistema complejo pero en
realidad no lo es tanto Singapur cuenta
ya con cinco plantas New water que se
dedican a recuperar aguas residuales y
una sexta entrada en funcionamiento en
el año 2025 y vale Seguro seguro que os
estáis preguntando pero este agua se
bebe Pues sí La respuesta es que sí esa
agua perfectamente aprovechable para el
consumo humano de hecho el proceso de
New water ha superado más de 150.000
pruebas científicas que le han hecho
conseguir el aprobado de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud y su calificación
como agua potable segura Ultra limpia
[Música]
a pesar de ello Y supongo que por una
cuestión de recelos no me digáis que
vosotros no lo tendríais el agua de New
water se suministra por lo general de
forma separada principalmente para usos
industriales y comerciales o por ejemplo
para sistemas de enfriamiento de aires
acondicionados de tamaño Industrial
porque sí en Singapur el aire
acondicionado que queréis que os diga es
un aparato fundamental pero ojo un
momento porque esto poco a poco está
cambiando una parte de este agua si se
utiliza ya para complementar el
suministro de agua potable doméstica
como puede ser bombea una parte de ella
y se mezcla con el agua de los embalses
destinados al consumo doméstico y claro
teniendo en cuenta las limitaciones que
existen y el agua bombeada por New water
para consumo doméstico va cobrando cada
vez más y más importancia y de hecho se
espera que para el año 2060 suponga más
de la mitad de todo el consumo de agua
amigos amigas ni siquiera Israel ha
llegado hoy pro y tan lejos y luego por
último tendríamos el agua desalinizada
esta cuarta fuente nacional no es tan
novedosa desde hace mucho tiempo la
podemos encontrar casi por todas partes
[Música]
actualmente Singapur cuenta con cuatro
desalinizadoras que son capaces de
satisfacer un elevado porcentaje de la
demanda de agua tanto es así que la idea
es que para 2060 el agua desalenizada
surta hasta el 30% de la demanda
nacional lo que he sumado al agua
procedente del New water se espera que
garantice hasta el 85% del consumo de
agua nacional permitiendo además contar
con importantes reservas de agua dulce
en la red de almacenamiento principal
no os parece algo realmente increíble
desde luego si tenemos en cuenta tanto
el caso de Israel como el de Singapur
parece que cuando se habla de escasez de
agua no sé se quiere decir sobre todo
mala gestión del agua
[Música]
El caso es que con este plan es como
Singapur es para lograr la
autosuficiencia para el año 2061 cuando
expire el contrato de importación de
agua de Malasia en ese momento se espera
que los cuatro grifos nacionales se
conviertan en tres Y sí obviamente este
plan conlleva un esfuerzo titánico e
importantes inversiones que por supuesto
no son gratis Singapur subirá el precio
del agua un 30% en dos años Claro que
por otra parte Singapur puede llegar a
convertirse en un futuro próximo en un
importante exportador de tecnologías de
gestión aprovechamiento y tratamiento de
agua no sé pensad lo que estas técnicas
supondrían en países como Arabia Saudita
Qatar emiratos árabes o incluso en un
sitio con una gestión de agua tan
desastrosa como la India y qué queréis
que os diga si alguien sabe hacer dinero
esos son precisamente las gentes de
Singapur no os parece Eso sí dinero a
cambio de prosperidad y agua dulce para
todos pero amigos llegados Hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que los avances
tecnológicos permitirán solucionar en el
futuro los problemas de agua en el mundo
y con ellos los posibles retos políticos
que puedan surgir supondrá la tecnología
por el fin de la escasez de agua déjanos
por aquí abajo tus comentarios y si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante No
olvides darle a like y suscribiros a
visualpolitik y muy importante si te
gusta lo que hacemos y quieres más te
invitamos a sumarte a nuestra comunidad
de patio además de contribuir a que
sigamos creando contenido independiente
podrás recibir las claves de la semana
la tan político productos exclusivos
entre otras muchas cosas os dejamos el
enlace por aquí abajo en la descripción
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]